[Musique]
cette semaine marque la deuxième étape
du déconfinement et du retour à la
normale de la vie des yvelinois
depuis mercredi les restaurants peuvent
enfin installer leurs clients en
intérieur et rester ouverts plus tard
jusqu'à 23 heures
d'autres lieux ont également pu rouvrir
leurs portes salle de sport cours de
yoga ou encore piscine à l'image des
bassins des clayes-sous-bois qui
accueille de nouveau les nageurs après
huit mois de fermeture
avec l'été qui se prépare certains
établissements peinent à employer les
saisonniers se sont pour certains des
tournées du secteur faute d'ouverture
incertaine et tardif au parc de loisirs
france miniature à elancourt par exemple
certains postes se sont encore vacants
de lundi à vendredi la ville de
rambouillet a ouvert un vaxy drive fnra
l'hippodrome attentes des placements et
vaccins tout s'y est fait en voiture un
système rapide et réitérée dans six
semaines pour permettre à environ 2000
personnes de recevoir leurs deux
injections
le personnel des mairies mobilisés
depuis plusieurs jours pour préparer la
double élection des 20 et 27 juin
prochain entre bonne coordination et
mesures sanitaires l'objectif est
d'accueillir les 1 million 400 mille
yvelinois en sécurité dans les bureaux
de vote
enfin du sport le président de la
république a rendu visite à l'équipe de
france de football à clairefontaine ce
jeudi 10 juin
accompagné de son épouse brigitte
macondé président de la fédération
française de football et de la fifa
emmanuel macron est venu encourager les
bleus pour l'euro 2020 qui débutera
mardi 15 juin prochain face à
l'allemagne
[Musique]